j'ouvre tout de suite notre second débat
dans ce sens public débat d'actualité
pour analyser les conséquences du
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle en Turquie contrairement
à ce qu'a annonçait les sondages c'est
ragep tape Erdogan qui est arrivé en
tête
49,5 % des voix à 288
000 voix près il aurait pu être élu dès
le premier tour vient ensuite celui qui
était donné comme le favori Kemal kilich
daroglou à 44,9 et puis ici la nogan on
vous le présentera tout à l'heure un peu
plus de 5% des voix en détail ces
résultats et les réactions avec Cécile
Sixu après une nuit d'attente c'est
désormais officiel les électeurs Turcs
retourneront aux urnes le 28 mai
prochain
a créé la surprise le président sortant
que les sondages disaient à la traîne
frôlent l'élection dès le premier tour
avec
49,5% des suffrages son adversaire qui
est mal kiliche Daru lui a obtenu 44,9%
des votes des hier soir les deux
prétendants
si notre nation demande un second tour
nous l'acceptons volontiers et nous
allons absolument gagner ce second tour
tout le monde va y assister
nous savons pas encore si l'élection est
terminée avec ce premier tour et si le
peuple nous emmène au second tour on le
respecterons
90% des électeurs Turcs ont votés une
forte mobilisation saluée par Ursula
vanderleyen la présidente de la
Commission européenne
je pense que la participation massive à
ces élections est vraiment une bonne
nouvelle est-ce que tu dois de nouvelles
car c'est un signe très clair que le
peuple turc s'engage à exercer son droit
démocratique d'aller voter et qu'ils
apprécient les institutions
démocratiques
c'est une grande victoire pour le second
tour des présidentielles les regards se
tournent désormais vers le report des
voies du 3e candidat sinanogan il a
obtenu 5% des suffrages pas de second
tour en revanche pour les élections
législatives remportées des IR par la
cape le parti d'erdoine
j'accueille tout de suite mes invités
dans ce second débat j'étais en train de
vérifier quelques informations
concernant évidemment ces élections en
Turquie Pascal Boniface bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes géopolitologue
directeur de l'Institut de relation
internationale et stratégique et vous
publiez comprendre le monde les
relations internationales expliquées à
tous c'est aux éditions Armand Colin
nord-racini bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
historienne professeur émérite des
universitaires à l'Institut français
géopolitique de l'Université Paris 8 et
ancienne directrice de l'Institut
français d'études anatoliennes
fondatrice de ce journal en ligne
observatoire de la Turquie contemporaine
d'elizuna al bonsoir bienvenue à vous
aussi vous êtes économiste au Centre
d'études prospective et d'information
internationales bienvenue à vous
j'accueille avec nous en duplex le
sénateur Jean-Yves Leconte sénateur
socialiste des Français établit hors de
France et vous étiez à Istanbul vous
êtes à Istanbul vous y étiez en mission
d'observation
électorale bienvenue à vous
[Musique]
selon toutes vraisemblance s'il devrait
confirmer aux élections présidentielle
sa victoire au législatives et je le
disais en lancement du sujet de Cécile
c'est que moi il lui a manqué moins de
300 000 voix pour être élu dès le
premier tour nos racines pourquoi
d'après vous les instituts sondages
ont-ils sous-estimé Erdogan comment vous
l'analyser ça
il y a encore un soupçon de fraude quand
même un tout petit peu même si c'est à
la marge mais il y a quand même un petit
voilà et puis le carburant de la
campagne de
la
le l'espoir l'espoir et une joie
anticipée si vous voulez et ça était
quelque chose qui les a porté d'ailleurs
on voit que ça ça donnait une vision sur
la dimension d'espoir qui avait dans ce
dans ce pays pour la démocratie pour
plus de liberté pour l'État de droit
pour les ailes peut-être que les je me
on se demande si les jours n'ont pas
répondu à côté n'ont pas répondu
pas comme ils allaient voter vraiment
il y a les réponses qu'on donne aux
enquêtes et la réponse qui vient de
devant les urnes ça c'est une chose et
puis il y a peut-être quelque chose de
lors d'une on considère cette
participation à la aux élections quelque
chose comme 90% c'est du jamais vu nulle
part mais les Turcs ont en effet cette
habitude de voter massivement et c'est
alors le Nord mais il y a quelque chose
là-dedans qui dépasse le civisme et qui
est la peur que l'Autre
Campagne et ça donne une vision de la
polarisation de ce pays avec deux clans
deux sociétés de culture qui craignent
la le pouvoir de l'autre mais vraiment
je veux dire qui craignent par exemple
que les que les laïcs craignent quand
les confinissent par obtenir deux qui se
s'habillent d'une certaine façon que sur
les places publiques ils ne consomment
pas qu'il n'est pas les mêmes types de
loisirs qu'ils ont l'habitude d'avoir
sur les modes sur l'habillement sur la
mixité homme-femme dans la ville sur
l'espace public et tout ça ils ont peur
que il y a eu déjà une avancée si vous
voulez de l'islamisation par le bas
lentement de la société avec et puis où
on ne sait pas où cela société polarisée
peut-être fracturé on y reviendra
évidemment et on parlera peut-être des
peurs de de l'autre camp dans dans un
instant denizuma ounale le le candidat
de l'opposition qui est mal kilijarolu
est à la tête d'une coalition qui est
assez hétéroclite est-ce que ça ça a pu
jouer c'est-à-dire qu'à un moment où les
électeurs effectivement entre le la
réponse à l'institut de sondage on est
un peu dans l'espoir et puis le moment
où on vote et on se dit mais est-ce
qu'ils vont réussir à gouverner est-ce
que cette coalition va réussir à
gouverner est-ce que ça a pu jouer ça
pour vous
l'Union nécessite le compr un langage
beaucoup plus complexe aller vers
l'autre expliquez des choses compliquées
notamment même dans le domaine de
l'économie parce que on est dans une
crise qui peut devenir très très grave
en Turquie et face à ça le langage de
l'exécutif et simple et ben on vous fait
des cadeaux électoraux on vous fait des
aides directes vous pouvez même pas le
gaz et il faut aussi
considérer qu'il y a toute une partie de
la population
en particulier un Anatolie qui est
embauché
par la fonction publique qui est aussi
du certain manière bénéficier qui
bénéficie des projets de l'État il y a
tout ça qui entre en jeu et enfin c'est
vrai n'aura génial a raison on est dans
une société non seulement polarisée mais
avec une propagande tellement massive
on en parle pas comme si on avait passé
des élections normales non la propagande
a été massive et l'opposition avec
c’était plus difficile pour l'opposition
se faire entendre d'accéder aux médias
comment ça s'est passé
corrigeois c'est jeudi je fais une
erreur mais je crois que par exemple
elle donne a eu 60 fois plus de de temps
de parole que son concurrent donc c'est
ça fait déjà ça et puis moi j'aimerais
bien vous rappeler
là pour nous expliquer par exemple aux
élections américaines je ne sais pas qui
a été l'écart mais dans une société
aussi polarisée c'est très difficile
d'utiliser un langage complexe un
langage où on parle des institutions on
parle de la démocratie par rapport à des
candidats hyper polarisants et la
Turquie et sous le même régime
maintenant aller disons depuis 10 ans on
était entré dans ce langage polarisant
alors je voudrais donner la parole
puisqu'on se poser la question à une
première fois des des fraudes à
Jean-Yves Leconte j'espère que la
liaison est correcte parce qu'on a eu
quelques petites soucis pour la pour la
régler donc je rappelle que vous êtes
sur place en Turquie pour une mission
d'observation électorale à quel point ce
scrutin était surveillé et comment
raconter nous votre expérience
en fait les autorités turques avaient
invité à la fois le Conseil de l'Europe
et et
l'Assemblée parlementaire de Elodie à
faire des missions d'observation
électorale sur l'ensemble du pays donc
j'ai fait partie des parlementaires qui
n'ont plus
observer moi je suis allé dans la région
de diabati pour voir la manière dont
s'ouvrait un bureau de vote son dérouler
le vote tout au long de la journée et la
manière dont on clôturé le scrutin et
donc c'était quand les les votes donc
voilà donc j'ai pu effectivement voir
des bureaux de vote des petits pots de
vote mais avec de très grosses
participations avec en plus étonnamment
des des horaires de vote finalement
assez courtes puisque ça s'ouvre à 8h et
ça ferme à 17h partout dans le pays même
dans les grandes villes et deux heures
avant la fermeture du scrutin nous
avions déjà dans certains bureau de vote
plus de 80% de participation c'est quand
même absolument étonnant par rapport à
ce que nous pouvons constater dans dans
dans nos pays voilà dans le cadre le
cadre dans lequel j'étais ce qui m'a
permis effectivement de faire certaines
observations et avec le reste avec vous
parce que la liaison est correcte des
observateurs des deux parties qui
étaient systématiquement présents alors
je m'appuie uniquement sur les bureaux
dans lesquels vous êtes allés
bien entendu les observateurs
internationaux à bouger partout dans le
dans
le pays dans les zones
dans les zones tous les organisations
internationales attribuent alors que
dans chaque bureau de vote vous avez une
partie de la composition des des des
membres de la commission électorale qui
sont des représentants de principes
politiques et que vous avez l'ensemble
des partis politiques qui ont la
possibilité de nommer des observateurs
et partout je me suis déplacé il y avait
un ou deux observateurs de parti
politique mais faut noter que même dans
la même intervacuer ou il y a quand même
largement un vote très très massif pour
le YSP le nouveau nom du HTP à votre
massif et où la cape est vraiment pas
favorite vous aviez quand même dans tous
les droits de vote des observateurs du
parti du parti de One et c'est même
assez étonnant de voir qu'ils étaient
absolument partout
dans cette partie de la Turquie pour
faire finalement leur fonction
d'observateurs au titre de ce parking
mais parfois d'aller un petit peu plus
loin c'est clairement je ne sais pas si
ça a pu changer le résultat du scrutin
mais le fait est que il prenait parfois
un peu leurs aises dans les bureaux de
vote bon merci pour ce témoignage restez
avec nous j'aurais encore plusieurs
questions à vous poser Jean-Yves Leconte
vous lire et agir
il y a eu des images
oui on parle de fraude il y a eu des
images de justement de scrutateurs
étrangers et locaux qui ont été empêchés
au moment de
au moment de comptage de gagner les
bureaux il faisait la queue devant les
devants les bureaux
et il n'était pas autorisés entre elles
mais mais vraiment très nombreux on a eu
ces images là je ne sais pas comment les
interpréter plus que ça mais il y a eu
des images donc de gens qui étaient
prévus pour être scrutateur et qui n'ont
pas pu mais des masses et qui n'ont pas
pu gagner les bureaux comme il était
prévu parce qu'elle Boniface on l'a
donné le chiffre de la participation 80%
de 90% de participation c'est
effectivement massif et donc ça donne
aussi un impulsion un éventuel mandat
renouvellement de mandat pour pour erdan
mais c'est pas le seul alors ça on
pourrait se dire c'est l'indication ou
le symptôme d'une démocratie qui va bien
sauf qu'il y a pas que ça il y a
beaucoup à dire sur la démocratie turque
aujourd'hui quoi c'est vrai que nous on
associe très souvent en France
démocratie avec le droit de voter mais
ça suffit pas il faut aussi qu'un État
droit faut aussi que la justice soit
indépendante qui est pas tout à fait le
cas seulement qu'on puisse dire en
Turquie que la presse soit libre or la
presse est majoritairement aux mains des
partisans d'Erdogan donc oui les gens
ont voté ont voté massivement mais on
peut dire que le le modèle de la
démocratie il libérale où on vote mais
c'est pas tout à fait l'état droit
s'applique fort bien à la Turquie c'est
quand même impressionnant c'est que
comme vous l'avez dit la Turquie c'était
cliver très divisé c'est pas la seule
mais en fait aux États-Unis ou en France
où nous sommes aussi clivés divisés nous
devons-t-on pas avec cette fougue et
donc il y a quand même une très forte
mobilisation mais effectivement en
Turquie comme ailleurs deux pays qui se
regardent et chacun craint que l'autre
Vienne menacer la Turquie telle qu'il
pense qu'elle doit être avec une crainte
pour démocrate et libéraux que la
réélection d’erdogan Vienne encore un
peu plus fermer la parenthèse
démocratique et venir encore un peu plus
et tout fait les libertés et la crainte
des partitions d'Erdogan que la Turquie
soit plus tout à fait un pays musulman
et tels qu'ils le voient si l'opposition
l'emportait donc il y a vraiment un
clivage très fort alors justement dans
ces muscles vous avez fait la première
partie de la démonstration tout à
l'heure parce qu'elle manifeste là un
peu complété à l'instant mais que
craignent les les soutiens d'erdoğan
dans ce dans cette polarisation elle
doit un socle de des lecteurs très fort
et assez immuable si vous voulez qui
n'ont sensible ni
vis-à-vis de la de la crise économique
ni le tremblement de terre se fait au
moins une une
proportion de 30 à 40% de l'électorat
qui est prudher don quoi qu'il advienne
et quand on leur parle de crise et de la
de l'augmentation du prix de la tomate
de l'oignon comme
cristal on doit faire sa campagne sur le
prix de l'oignon etc oui c'était filmé
dans sa cuisine
sur une démonstration de l'inflation
exactement et ils disent nous mangeons
des pierres mais nous voterons
parce qu'il lui doivent tout hardwan a
fait émerger une classe moyenne dont il
faut partir de rien du tout si vous
voulez il a résolvé les le logement
insalubre etc il y a eu des villes
nouvelles avec des des immeubles tout à
fait corrects même si il ressemble au
HLM et ville nouvelle un peu inhumaine
de nos civilisations mais du coup mais
surtout il leur parle
en faisant bien sentir que il y a une
continuum culturel idéologique entre lui
et ils font partie de la même
sensibilité très
très musulmane assez
particulière pas très pas informé mais
pas très
scolarisé
du logement et nous on avait lu que
depuis le tremblement de terre au
contraire le dossier du logement était
en train de devenir un boulet pour
erdoğan parce que beaucoup de
construction après les précédents
séismes n'avaient pas respecté les
normes mais ça lui a été reproché
peut-être Denis parce que il a promis
effectivement de reconstruire notamment
dans la dans la région le travers par le
séisme non c'est vrai que quand on parle
de la classe moyenne peut-être que dans
la première décennie il y a eu cette
classe moyenne vous avez raison mais
après il n'y a plus maintenant de classe
moyenne en Turquie parce que il y a une
augmentation des inégalités telles que
vous avez été très riche et des très
pauvres et
l'ensemble des pauvres commence à être
la majorité de la population on est dans
la grande pauvreté on a 12 millions de
personnes dans la pauvreté en Turquie
à part les gens qui vont au dessus un
peu qui sont au-dessus de la
communication malgré cette crise
économique très lourde il y a pas eu une
sanction majeure de du sortant ça peut
sembler justement je reviens dans un
pays où quand on revient à la
construction aussi on dit bah évidemment
il y a un danger énorme pour l'ensemble
des constructions et
Istanbul on attend d'ici maintenant tout
de suite ou bien dans 30 ans on connaît
pas exactement mais il y aura une
catastrophe majeure on est sur des
feuilles à ist or la densité de la
population est telle que et les
constructions ont été faits d'une
manière tellement contraire à ce qu'il
fallait faire qu'on aura un impact 5
fois plus que ce qu'on a eu dans le
double séisme parce que vous savez quand
même un cinquième de la population qui
habite à Istanbul dans une urbanisation
sauvage donc dans ces conditions là il y
a toujours des idées de court terme et
des idées de long terme structurel ce
que elle donne arrive à faire passer et
ben voilà je vous dis ça toujours avec
des coups de menton ou des politiques à
court terme il arrive à séduire un
électorat qui ne regarde pas beaucoup
plus loin parce que c'est caricatural si
je dis que le vote le plus populaire
effectivement le moins éduqué le moins
scolarisé et pour erdoğan et le vote à
l'inverse plus plus bourgeois plus CSP
plus c'est ça il y a les villes les
campagnes comme dans d'autres pays on a
cette division dans notre pays je pense
aussi ordergen a eu un succès et colique
au départ les 10 premières années il
quadruple PIB par habitant donc c'est
sauf que là il y a eu un refus et on est
revenu à la situation en 2023 on est
comme en 2007-2008 donc il y a eu un
approvision et moi je mon intervient
serait que finalement le consommateur a
perdu devant le patriote c'est à dire
que le côté fierté nationale en plus les
Turcs qui vivent à l'étranger eux ne
sont pas atteints par la crise
économique parce qu'ils votent en
Allemagne en France la crise économique
de Zana pas et ils sont bien quand même
que la Turquie est mal considérée en
Europe qu'il y a beaucoup de Turquie
machines que le débat public notamment
en France mais pas seulement n'est pas
très favorable à la Turquie c'est un
euphémisme et donc il y a une sorte de
de dire ben voilà vous nous aimez pas et
on va voter pour celui qui nous défend
contre cela parce que ce qui est quand
même ce qu'on ne dit pas assez c'est que
lorsqu'il garde au pouvoir en 2002 il
apparaît comme un libéral il veut
garantir dire les droits de la
communauté LGBT il est pro européen et
tout a disparu donc qu'est-ce qui s'est
mal passé peut-être que la façon disons
peu élégante à laquelle on a claqué la
porte de l'Union européenne à la Turquie
a été intégrée et à suscité ce qu'on
peut appeler une crise passion en tous
les cas un réflexe nationaliste sur
lequel Erdogan surf alors ça je vous
propose d'y revenir un peu plus tard sur
le les rapports de la Turquie avec
l'Europe et et la France mais je
voudrais rester sur la question des des
fraudes de soupçons de fraude pour
l'instant à ma connaissance il y a pas
eu de contestation formelle du camp qui
arrive en seconde position depuis hier
soir il y a quand même une image une
vidéo qui circule beaucoup depuis hier
on y voit le président sortant je
propose de voir tout de suite ces images
on y voit donc Récept one qui distribue
des billets il est à la sortie du de son
bureau de vote vidéo qui a été
authentifiée par nos confrères de
libération
bon c'est du je sais pas comment on peut
appeler ça clientélisme
assumer oui mais les enfants ils sont
venus avec leurs parents qui qui
venaient voter j'arrive le compte c'est
du clientélisme vu d'ici ces images sont
ultra choquantes est-ce que vous avez
assisté à des scènes similaires là où
vous étiez et encore une fois quel est
le climat aujourd'hui vous qui voilà est
en Turquie sur ces soupçons ou c'est
l'accusations éventuelles de fraude
non moi j'ai rien entendu j'ai rien vu
j'ai rien vu de tel moi j'avais plutôt
envie un peu de réagir sur ce qui était
dit auparavant d'abord pour interroger
si vous voulez sur une île sur une
question il y a quelque chose qui
devrait tous nous interroger lorsqu'on
parle de cette élection c'est la raison
qui explique que le vote de la diaspora
à turque dans les pays européens et ça
rejoint finalement un peu les
explications qui pouvaient être donné
par
Pascal Boniface sur finalement les 10
premières années d'Erdogan qui ont
vraiment permis à la Turquie d'évoluer
de manière positive et qui font qu'en
réalité aujourd'hui le vote il a
effectivement ville campagne mais il est
aussi tout à fait générationnel on
espérait finalement en tout cas
l'opposition espérer que les 6 millions
de nouveaux électeurs allaient changer
la donne mais visiblement finalement
ceux qui se rappellent encore de ce que
était la Turquie d'avant des années 90
est-ce que la Turquie a pu vivre comme
l'évolution au cours des années 2000
malgré tout encore dominant dans la
manière dont il perçoivent
la raison pour laquelle ils ont voté
même si les difficultés actuelles
rencontrées par le pays que ce soit en
matière économique ou que ce soit les
sites du séisme on conduit finalement à
mon avis la cape à peut-être remporté le
scrutin le nous verrons bien enfin en
tout cas pour les parlementaires mais
très largement à crédit très largement à
crédit contenu des engagements qui ont
été pris mais vraiment il faut voir que
je pense que c'est c'est encore par
rapport à la manière dont la Turquie a
évolué de 2000 à 2013 qui explique
l'attachement d'une partie des électeurs
à
[Musique]
Erdogan et à la cape et il faut vraiment
avoir ça en tête lorsqu'on essaie de de
comprendre la situation parce que ceux
qui voulaient le changement finalement
ils avaient fait l'union avec des des
orientations très différentes des
sociaux-démocrates
nationaliste mais aussi le parti qui est
plutôt à dominante kurde et tout ceci
pas vraiment ensemble mais en voulant
finalement forger une alliance
d'alternance mais ça n'a pas suffi par
rapport à ce que représente encore
visiblement la cape dans la population
c'est ce qu'on évoquait tout à l'heure
et on y reviendra avec notamment les
résultats du du Perlo du Parlement merci
beaucoup
j'aurais le compte quand même je reviens
sur ces images parce que bon là on est
passé on les a vu ultra rapidement on
est passé dessus comme si de rien
n'était mais est-ce que c'est
on dit c'est c'est enfin c'est il y aura
un scandale national en Turquie ça passe
visiblement pub elle doit sa première
visite sur les lieux du séisme donc de
deux trois jours après le désastre il
est venu en distribuant des billets
toujours aux enfants comme qu'on envoie
un peu voilà et ça a l'air de ne poser
aucun problème à personne mais c'est
exactement de ça qu'il s'agit si vous
c'est une espèce de figure paternelle
omnipotente qui est capable de tout
c'est devenu une espèce de hier dans son
dans son allocution du balcon il a
commencé par dire voilà c'est notre
amour c'est notre c'est notre passion
les uns pour les autres comme s'il
parlait d'une vraie passion de de de une
personne vis-à-vis d'une autre relation
amoureuse voilà tout à fait elle a
commencé par commencer par chanter une
quelque chanson tout à fait sucrée et
puis des poèmes et une déclaration comme
ça de et ça marche et ça marche il y a
une population qui l'attendait il était
2h30 du matin
d'Istanbul et ça ça marche je voudrais
revenir juste sur le sur un point c'est
que encore une fois ce qui unit
susceptible de se laisser
adoucir ou
[Musique]
diffuser comme dissous ni par les crises
économiques oui par c'est le parce qu'on
se demande s'il y aura un effet séisme
ni pas les questions de liberté la
question de toutes les questions de
liberté de ce que nous appelons la
démocratie ne semble pas les toucher des
maisonnades est-ce que vous reprenez la
formule de Pascal Boniface les patriotes
l'ont emporté sur les consommateurs
je dirais pas consommateur mais sur les
citoyens
en fait les nationalistes ont remporté
sur les citoyens et
c'est à craindre c'est un beaucoup de
pays maintenant on voit ces tendances
pas uniquement dans les pays
autocratiques petit à petit ça
s'installe et quand les électeurs les
électeurs nationalistes sont quand même
des citoyens
ensuite quelles sont les valeurs qu'on a
un culte aux gens il faut reconsidérer
comment ces élections se sont passées à
l'avance vous avez le un parti HTP qui a
préféré au dernier moment ne pas se
présenter aux élections parce qu'ils
étaient pratiquement sûr qu'ils allaient
te fermer par décision de justice donc
ISO du se mettre dans un autre partie
pour pouvoir quand même
exister et par ailleurs qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé le maire d'Istanbul a été
accusé lui aussi de je ne sais plus
est-ce que on était dans une corruption
ou de menaces terrorisme que voilà et
lui non plus il a pas pu se présenter
lui c'est un cadre candidat brillant et
tout le monde pensait que d'ailleurs les
autres parties insistez vous que ce soit
analyser ce scrutin avec notre seul
regard de de démocrates occidentale ça a
été un scrutin mais vous faites de
l'oppression dans le pays où il n'y a
plus de justice personne ne peut vous
défendre vous avez l'armée la police
contre vous et vous n'arrivez même pas à
vous exprimer normalement et après vous
faites des élections dans des conditions
très très difficile et vous vous étonnez
à vraiment les électeurs élisent quand
même ces gens là mais dans quelles
conditions on est dans des sociétés qui
n'ont plus les mêmes valeurs et qui
n'ont plus les institutions comme ils
avaient à l'ancien le Parlement ne
représente plus rien en Turquie et par
rapport à ça moi je suis économiste la
banque centrale
turque actuellement c'est une coquille
vide on a vu pendant les le tremblement
de terre et bien le Croissant Rouge
était devenu effectivement s'occuper
plutôt des consommateurs le croissant en
rouge c'était il avait commencé à
commercialiser des tentes et que n'avait
plus de temps pour son propre compte on
était dans cet état là alors je propose
de voir on déjà fait un petit focus sur
le résultat
des élections législatives donc il y a
une chambre unique au Parlement la
Grande Assemblée nationale de Turquie
qui compte 600 députés au total le
parking le parti du président Rdom dans
la législature précédente il bénéficiait
de 42% des des voix seulement 35% cette
fois-ci ça fait 267 difficultés sur 600
ça recule quand même important pour
l'ACP la CAPEP le parti d'erdoine
ensuite le principal parti d'opposition
lui progresse mais pas tant que ça de 22
à 25% ça fait 168 députés et si on
résume on a un erdon qui reste dominant
au Parlement notamment grâce à son
alliance avec les ultras nationalistes
il devrait conserver une majorité de 321
députés sur 600 Pascal Boniface quand on
dit ça on imagine un Parlement mais
effectivement le le pouvoir du Parlement
et puis d'une manière générale les
contre-pouvoirs se sont réduits au fur
et à mesure des dernières années d'une
dérive autoritaire de d'erdoğan
il y a beaucoup spirituels qui soient
avocats journalistes professeur à
l'université qui ont quitté le pays
parce qu'il craignent pour leur liberté
ils craignent d'être soumis à un procès
d'être emprisonné et certains sont
emprisonnés et donc il y a disons que
tous ceux pour lequel la liberté
d'expression est un critère important de
leur vie quotidienne beaucoup d'entre
eux sont partis espérés pouvoir revenir
en cas d'inversion des résultats et sont
plutôt desespérés ce matin de se dire et
ben que finalement leur exil va
continuer encore assez longtemps c'est
une réalité et donc effectivement une
fois encore on vote les élections
honnêtement je pense que l'afro doit
être existe mais doit être marginale on
dirait on ne peut pas expliquer ces cinq
points d'écart par l'afrod et mais voilà
disons que la réalité elle est
désagréable mais c'est une réalité et
donc ce n'est pas le candidat favori des
Européens qui a gagné et ce sont les
Turcs qui ont voté alors oui il y a bien
sûr des biais sur la presse etc mais on
va être le confronter à quelques années
de plus avec Erdogan et il risque de
naître pas prêt à beaucoup de compromis
après un tel succès électoral quel qu'en
soit les racines et le fait de dire que
bon le débat était pas libre que les
médias étaient pour lui et il est là
pour les prochaines années et que Ben
d'ailleurs ce qui était très frappant
c'est que la plupart des dirigeants
européens souhaitaient la victoire de
l'opposition mais n'ont rien dit d'une
part pour ne pas antagoniser un peu plus
les relations avec les Doan et puis
surtout Far Cry très naturel dire si on
soutient le gain de l'opposition on
pourra Erdogan pour encore plus
facilement le faire passer pour le
candidat de l'étranger ce qui nulle part
dans aucun pays n'abonne presse Mathieu
si on fait un peu un focus entre des
relations entre récepts et Emmanuel
Macron qu'est-ce qu'on peut en dire on
peut dire que c'est pas bon
nos épouses s'entendent bien pas nous ça
c'est ce qu'avait dit récepté hyperdogan
à l'automne dernier lors d'un sommet
après et c'est vrai que les deux
premières dames peuvent bien s'entendre
mais en revanche les deux présidents pas
du tout et pourtant on savait commencer
Emmanuel Macron avait reçu
erdouan en janvier 2018 donc après son
arrivée à l'Élysée de la même manière
qu'il avait vous souvenez reçu aussi
l'univers Poutine à Versailles il
faisait le tour pour se présenter mais
l'entente n'a pas duré parce qu'il y a
trop de points de désaccord des points
de désaccord en géopolitique il y en a
eu beaucoup il y a eu sur le rôle de la
Turquie en Libye il y a eu sur les
explorations turques vous souvenez en
Méditerranée orientale qui avait fâché
la Grèce il y a eu le soutien dans ka à
l'Azerbaïdjan dans le conflit contre
l'Arménie donc il y a eu beaucoup
beaucoup de d'un point de vue
géopolitique beaucoup de points de
dissension et puis il y a des points
politiques internes je veux dire aussi
avec les mesures qui a pu prendre la
France souvenez-vous à l'automne 2020 la
loi dite contre les séparatismes qui est
devenu un loi pour renforcer les piliers
de la République je serai plus forcément
de son nom mais cette loi là elle a
beaucoup excité la Turquie qui nourrit
il faut le dire aussi vis-à-vis de la
France des antagonistes qui date pas
d'Emmanuel Macron la reconnaissance du
génocide arménien ou la première loi le
foulard islamique à l'école avait déjà
beaucoup irrité le pouvoir turc et là
quand la loi sur les séparatismes est
adoptée ça devient un objet de de
protestation de la part du président
erdouan qui insulte même Emmanuel Macron
vous en souvenez donc il ferait bien de
faire examiner sa santé mentale parce
que alors dans la loi il faut se
souvenir que on s'en prenait aussi
beaucoup au financement étranger de
l'islam en France et dans ce financement
étranger ça en France il y a aussi des
mosquées turques et des associations
dont la fameuse qui s'appelle minigorus
voilà mais qui était beaucoup mis en
cause par les autorités ensuite ils ont
tenté de se ravibaucher ça pas duré
longtemps et bien Macron a même
soupçonné un moment erdoğan de vouloir
faire ingérence dans la campagne
présidentielle française on était à
l'époque en avril 2021 ils disaient
attention aux ingérences Turcs dans la
campagne présidentielle française parce
qu'il y avait eu des ingérences Turcs
dans la campagne allemande précédente et
puis et puis ensuite ça s'est encore
radicalisé avec une chose c'est le
dossier rien et notamment la façon dont
la Turquie a traité les Kurdes qui
étaient de nos alliés et surtout l'axe
qui s'est dessiné entre en cas et Moscou
avec ce rapprochement
erdouan Vladimir Poutine qui a fait la
basculer complètement
erdoine dans un autre camp non assigné
est-ce que Emmanuel Macron est le
punching-ball favori de
Dean je ne crois pas je crois que ça ça
se joue entre l'Allemagne et la France à
se distribuer plus que pareil il avait
traité aussi Madame Merkel de de nazi
elle n'avait pas bien pris tout à fait
non c'était c'est une orientation
vis-à-vis du monde occidental c'est
aussi c'est autant une orientation
culturelle que géopolitique vous savez
que il a la Turquie a importé d'un
système de défense les S400
les voilà et à la Russie qui c'est un
système de défense totalement contre la
victoire avec le reste l'armement turc
qui est en harmonie avec celui de l'OTAN
donc c'est c'est
ce sont des moments de bravada parce que
c'est 400 n'ont pas été utilisé ne sont
nous ne sommes pas voués à l'utilisation
non plus donc elle doit une posture
qu'on peut qualifier autant de
d'autonomie de de cela mais que qui est
aussi culturel pour pour
la politique intérieure si vous voulez
nous ne sommes pas comme eux nous ne
sommes pas la démocratie ne veut pas
dire la même chose pour nous c'était là
parce que Boniface voudrait pousser un
peu la démonstration que vous avez
amorcé tout à l'heure est-ce que
l'Europe a une part de responsabilité
dans la dérive autoritaire d'erdoine
alors on peut pas dire que tout vient de
la faute de l'Europe mais expliquer
n'est pas légitimer et donc il faut
reconnaître quand même la façon donc
français allemand en 2016-2018 on dit on
dit au Turc vous négociez avec nous mais
quand vous êtes musulmans vous pourrez
jamais rentrer dans l'Union européenne
n'a pas été apprécié par les Turcs et
par l'opinion qui en a gardé un fort
ressorti alors après il y a aussi le
coup d'État raté de 2016 qui a compté
dans la dérive autoritaire d'Erdogan
mais quand même quand disons qui a perdu
la Turquie c'est la question qu'on peut
se poser rappelez-vous quand même
quelqu'un comme Michel Rocard qui n'est
pas un islamo gauchiste plaidait pour
l'intégration de la Turquie dans l'Union
européenne à terme et effectivement bah
l'erdogan d'aujourd'hui n'a rien à voir
avec celui des premières années et même
si il ne faut pas accablé l'Europe de
tous les mots mais en tous les cas on
n'a pas traité avec considération et de
même les Turcs estiment que les
Américains les ont pas non plus traité à
considération et donc la façon d'Erdogan
joue avec l'OTAN je suis dans l'OTAN
tout temps n'achetant des armes à la
Russie et en montant les émotion de la
Russie ça plaît beaucoup au Turc d'une
part parce que ça lui donne des marges
de manœuvre et on voit que même il
s'agit ne prennent pas de sanctions
contre la Turquie alors que la Turquie
n'applique pas les sanctions contre la
Russie la Turquie et le seul pays de
l'OTAN qui n'applique pas les sanctions
contre la Russie du fait de l'invasion
de l'Ukraine et là il y a une rancœur
rappelez-vous que la Turquie avait
refusé le passage des troupes
américaines en 2003 pour la guerre
d'Irak donc il y a eu quand même le
sentiment que on les a traités comme des
gens qui étaient au bout de la table qui
avait même pas le droit à ce strapontin
et Erdogan leur dit bah regardez je suis
un pays mais qui ce serait intéressé aux
élections turques qu'il y a 20 ans
est-ce qu'on aurait consacré des
émissions à publique César aux élections
turques qu'il y a maintenant
certainement pas donc il y a la
persillade qui joue mais il y a aussi le
fait objectif que la Turquie a une place
sur l'échiquier mondiale qui n'a rien à
voir avec celle qui était la sienne il y
a 20 ans vis-à-vis de l'Europe il y a
aussi un rééquilibrage du rapport de
force lié à la crise migratoire qui a
donné à r o n une position une position
de force vis-à-vis de l'Europe on était
déjà en 2015
pour pouvoir mais est-ce que je peux
lever sur la redonner la parole à la
responsabilité de l'Europe
on peut voir clairement que cela
correspond du point de vue des dates au
moment où elle doit c'était le refus de
l'Europe le moment où Madame Merkel et
Sarkozy disent à aldoğan
se fera jamais
et on fait avec des termes peu amen
c'est à ce moment-là que la Turquie
bifurque dans une politique de voisinage
ou Ardouane se met à espérer devenir le
grand chef du monde
la Méditerranée de l'Est du monde
musulman c'est à ce moment-là et avoir
une politique économique et
international qui est fondée là-dessus
donc c'est à ce moment-là 2007 2008
c'est au moment où l'Europe tourne le
dos beaucoup plus clairement la Turquie
de nationale les résultats de ce scrutin
c'est vrai que
erdoine arrive en tête on met il est en
bas l'otage ce qui lui était pas arrivé
la fois précédente et puis on l'a dit il
y a quand même une société polarisée
pour ne pas dire fracturer est-ce que ça
peut modifier sa façon de de gouverner
freiner cette dérive autoritaire dans
ton dont on parlait à l'instant un gros
problème là
d'ici les élections déjà on a 15 jours
est-ce que on va pouvoir
maintenir le taux de la livre turc par
rapport au dollar c'est très très
important parce que jusqu'à présent on
le maintient à coup de ventes de
réserves officielle de la Banque
centrale à tel point que la banque
centrale est à
-70 milliards de de dollars ce qui est
énorme si jamais il fallait les sortir
on peut pas les sortir ce qui peut nous
dire risque économique lourd qui pèse
sur la Turquie aujourd'hui oui parce que
c'est
bien
c'est ça que je veux dire comment il va
faire maintenant disons qu'il remporte
et est-ce qu'il va pouvoir vraiment
continuer avec
de la même manière qu'avant n'en faire
que sa tête ou avoir vraiment des gens
qualifiés autour de lui et confié
vraiment à des gens compétents la
gestion de l'économie
s'il ne le fait pas peut-être que ça
peut toujours aller pour des raisons
géopolitiques on peut emprunter là chez
les Saoudiens on peut aller voir du côté
des Chinois et on peut toujours se
remettre dans le jeu géopolitique et il
faut chercher là-dessus la Turquie est
un très grand émergent maintenant pour
sa zone pour sa région et que
aujourd'hui on est dans une dans une
RG ou politique où il y a de la place
pour certaines manœuvres Pascal Boniface
je trouve ça passionnant est-ce que
finalement ce futur mandat parce que la
probabilité que erdoğan soit élu était
très très forte il peut être attrapé par
la réalité économique ça peut être ça
finalement le la charpente de ce monde
et donc il fera peut-être obligé de
faire des concessions aux États-Unis
mais il a des alternatives effectivement
ça leur il fera qu'il remette un peu de
l'ordre aussi la corruption gagne aussi
importante et quand il y a une
corruption il y a quand même moins de
performances économiques ça c'est proche
se sont très fortement et on peut dire
que finalement les difficultés peuvent
sur le plan économique commencer parce
que là il a un peu mis la poussière sous
le tapis mais à force ça devient
difficile la campagne d'entre-deux-tours
il va y avoir une campagne qui voilà qui
qui continue
moi j'ai été frappé parce que vous avez
dit sur les temps de parole enfin on
peut espérer une campagne un peu
équitable entre les entre les deux tours
entre les deux finalistes non c'est
clair il faut pas arriver encore une
fois moi je j'assume mes questions de
béotien vous savez elle va pas changer
il n'y a aucune raison au contraire il
sera de plus en plus arrogant hier il a
dit certains sont au balcon l'autre dans
la danse dans leur cuisine bon voilà
c'est les il va il va pas arrêter de
invectiver le ces opposants
il a traité d'Ivan il va le traiter il
va revenir sur sur cette
modestie très très exubérante on va dire
parce que
une des raisons de la de ce que les
commentateurs disent une des raisons de
l'échec et de l'écart avec les avec les
les enquêtes c'est cette le fait que il
a certains qui parmi les
parmi sont électorales qui étaient
prêtes à tourner le dos qui n'ont pas pu
voter
cristallolo parce qu'il avait annoncé
publiquement qu'il était allévi donc
c'est avoir merci beaucoup merci à tous
je suis désolé le débat se termine et ça
ouvrait encore une une thématique
religieuse passionnante mais il faut
conclure Pascal Boniface je rappelle le
titre de votre livre Comprendre le monde
les relations internationales expliquées
à tous qui est publié c'est la septième
édition c'est ça publie aux éditions
Armand Colas voilà c'est la fin de ce
sens public je vous dis à demain